hola
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no no
[Música]
quiero comenzar contándoles sobre una de
las vivencias más intensas que me ha
tocado experimentar sucedió en la selva
chiapaneca por el rumbo de pijijiapan
una tarde en la que unos amigos y yo
todos biólogos estábamos en la montaña y
uno de mis amigos cometió el clásico
error de poner el pie antes que los ojos
con la mala fortuna de que su suela
aterrizará sobre una serpiente y no era
cualquier serpiente sino una novia que
una de las más peligrosas de aquella
zona que sintiéndose amenazada giró el
cuerpo y hundió las faltas en la pierna
de mi amigo aquí como la altura de
ahora para los que no lo sepan el veneno
del asno había casi es sumamente potente
posee cualidades que básicamente te lee
kuan los tejidos y te producen necrosis
hemorragias falla renal y a menos que
sea tratado de forma adecuada un riesgo
inminente de muerte no sé si ustedes han
estado en la situación como este y no me
refiero precisamente a ser mordidos por
una serpiente sino a cualquier accidente
que ponga en marcha la cuenta regresiva
y ante el cual hay que actuar de
inmediato
lo primero que sucedió aquella tarde es
que empezaron a brotar ideas de que era
lo que había que hacer algunas basadas
en películas francamente y otras en
mitos populares alguien propuso que
había que poner un torniquete alguien
más dijo que no que un torniquete sólo
pondría en riesgo la extremidad y que lo
que había que hacer era extraer el
veneno por medio de instrucción ambas
ideas muy malas y uno de los locales que
nos acompañaba dijo que lo que había que
hacer era meter a la serpiente en
alcohol y preparar un brebaje y nos
aseguró que su tío se había salvado así
en una situación similar saben que
tienen en común todos estos remedios
que si funcionan a veces pero no porque
sean efectivos para contrarrestar el
veneno sino porque la verdad es que las
serpientes venenosas suelen ser
recelosos a la hora de administrar su
cóctel tóxico lo prefieren usar para
comer para alimentarse y son las
situaciones extremas para defenderse
saben como determinarse de veneno no
quizá algún día les sea útil espero que
no sea el caso pero uno nunca sabe es
muy sencillo si te duele como si te
estoy a inyectando ácido entonces puedes
estar seguro que hay veneno y que más te
vale estar preparado ahora cuando las
serpientes muerden pero no no curan
venenos le llaman mordida seca y
dependiendo de la especie de esto pues
en el 10% de los casos o hasta en el 80
se dan cuenta lo que vamos llegando que
muchos de estos remedios tradicionales o
creencias populares basados en
experiencias previas funcionan porque en
primera instancia no había veneno
y entonces pues claro no importa que
hagas se va a salvar la persona y luego
vas a decir así es lo que hay que hacer
bueno en el caso de mi amigo si había
veneno y la situación era evidentemente
día muerte ahora siendo biólogo
llevábamos con nosotros algunos frascos
de anti veneno que realmente es el único
tratamiento exitoso en caso de
intoxicación y entonces lo que hicimos
fue básicamente bajarlo en la montaña
subirlo en carro ir a la clínica más
cercana porque otra noción de las
películas cuando hay una mordida de
serpiente uno o dos frascos de antídoto
no bastan si necesitan muchísimos a lo
largo de meses
así es que que es algo a mi amigo si le
quedaron ciertas secuelas no nos va a
mentir pero bastante menores que los
algo
contar con la información pertinente a
la hora de la crisis y confiar en la
ciencia
ahora permiten hacer una breve para
hablar citando una fábula de bill foster
wallace una tarde dos pececillos van
andando en el agua cuando se encuentra
con un peso mayor en dirección contraria
que se detiene los saluda chicos como
están hoy qué tal está el agua los dos
pececitos jóvenes pues el gran de vuelta
sigue en su camino y transcurridos unos
momentos uno se voltea y le pregunta al
otro qué carajos es el agua y en efecto
muchas veces no estamos conscientes ni
siquiera de los asuntos que me puedan
resultar más evidentes y la fuerza del
día no podría ser más arriesgada al fin
de cuentas se está batallando nuestra
propia supervivencia como especie en
esta era que llamamos de la información
pero que en verdad deberíamos llamar la
era de la desinformación porque nunca
antes había sido tan fácil diseminar
nociones falsas y arbitrarias a lo largo
y ancho de los cinco continentes la
única esperanza que tenemos para salir
airosos de estos duros retos que se
avecinan
es comenzar a conectar el conocimiento
científico con el grueso de la población
y hacerlo de modo que éste se torne en
una parte esencial de nuestra cultura de
otro modo nos arriesgamos a que la
brecha entre ciencia y sociedad se
vuelva cada vez más amplia y en estos
menesteres como cuando te muerde una
serpiente venenosa la ignorancia no
exime de responsabilidad al contrario
podemos citar el caso del movimiento
anti vacunas como ejemplo de ello un
movimiento sin sustento alguno al que
sin embargo se suman gente
cotidianamente y que comienza a tener
tales repercusiones en algunas
localidades que ya no puede ser visto
como un motivo de adicción personal sino
como una de salud pública en el sentido
de que esos miles de padres que no
vacunan a sus hijos no sólo los ponen en
riesgo a ellos sino a todos porque hacen
tambalear la inmunidad colectiva que
tanto trabajo ha costado establecer y si
vemos por ejemplo lo que está sucediendo
con los brotes de sarampión en algunos
países industrializados desarrollados
países en los que esta enfermedad se
consideró erradicada durante décadas nos
podemos dar una idea
de los alcances que tiene una carencia
de cultura científica porque eso se
reduce a este problema a una carencia
grave de cultura científica que se
manifiesta en el hecho de que la gente
ni siquiera sea capaz de discernir entre
el torrente de información a su alcance
cuál es la confiable y podríamos citar
casos mucho más urgentes y con alcances
más devastadores como el calentamiento
global que pese a todas las evidencias
todavía hay gente que se empeña en poner
en duda ahora quiero preguntarles quién
de aquí cree en la ciencia o confía en
la ciencia
bueno quiero decirles que es un público
anómalo en el buen sentido porque según
los datos de la encuesta sobre
percepción pública la ciencia y la
tecnología en méxico la mitad de la
población de nuestro país desconfía de
los científicos en parte por el cúmulo
de conocimientos que poseen y bueno no
vamos a negar que hay instancias en que
estas sospechas se pueden ver secundadas
los científicos como sucede en cualquier
otro gremio a veces dan su brazo a
torcer en favor de intereses privados de
estas transnacionales poderosas o
gobiernos corruptos pero aquí el punto
importante a recalcar es el siguiente
sin una cultura científica sólida los
ciudadanos no cuentan con las
herramientas necesarias para alzar la
voz y disputar tales acciones quiénes
son las personas más fáciles de
manipular
las que ven la tele todo el día las que
adolecen de conocimientos no hay que
olvidar que de la misma forma en que no
se puede apreciar lo que no se conoce
jamás se va a poder presionar aquello
que no se comprende y para los jóvenes
de la audiencia si sienten que esto no
les compete no no se sienten tocados por
lo que estamos hablando aquí quiere
decir que lo estamos haciendo muy mal
como sociedad porque ustedes van a ser
los que tengan a los de mando pronto y
el mundo se está volviendo tremendamente
complejo y está cambiando a pasos
agigantados créanme cuando les digo que
en 20 años cuando ustedes tengan más o
menos mi edad
también comprobarlo más o menos la
realidad va a ser muy distinta como es
ahora y no sé si sepan qué factores son
los que más influencia probarán tener
sobre este cambio
el historiador y autor rival no al
jardín postula que en los tres grandes
temas sobre los queríamos estar
cuestionando nuestros cientos a nuestros
gobernantes y futuros candidatos a
puestos de gobierno y recuerden que
ustedes van a votar pronto son el
calentamiento global la ingeniería
genética y el auge de la inteligencia
artificial porque estos campos más que
ningún otro van a cambiar o de hecho ya
están cambiando el mundo en el que
habitamos o si prefieren para que le
demos seguimiento a la metáfora del
principio esa agua en la que estamos
inmersos
insistamos entonces que es el agua
la respuesta depende un poco del
contexto histórico en el que nos
encontremos en el siglo 19 fútbol no los
reveló al darle sentido y concepción a
concierto mismo de naturaleza porque con
bolt no sólo era un naturalista
remarcable sino antes que nada un gran
divulgador
yo diría que ese su legado más
importante la determinación de que los
conocimientos tienen que ser compartidos
intercambiados y puestos a la
disposición de todos y esto haciéndolo
del mundo de un modo profundamente
humanista y rico en aspectos literarios
hoy en día sin embargo estas cualidades
se han perdido de los programas de
estudio en casi ninguna escuela de
ciencias se le enseña a los alumnos a
escribir bien bien pocas instituciones
se insta a los investigadores a
comunicar sus hallazgos de una manera
creativa para todos esto tiene que
cambiar los científicos nos tienen que
informar no solo de sus avances sino
cómo llegaron a ellos porque son
remarcables para su campo de estudio y
en qué sentido podrían ser relevantes
para la sociedad ahora con esto no
quiere decir que la ciencia debería ser
utilitaria no lo debe hacer pero si ella
puede ser puesta en perspectiva para que
la sociedad comprenda su valía
melissa marshall la comunicóloga lo
resume con la siguiente fresa
para la población la ciencia que no es
comunicada es ciencia que no ha sido
hecha
y ya que estamos en esta la comunicación
misma de la ciencia necesitará una buena
apretada de tuercas necesitamos comenzar
a sacar a la ciencia de sus espacios
convencionales y colocarlas dentro de la
oferta habitual de entretenimiento los
bares cantinas parques museos son muy
buenos lugares para empezar esto porque
permiten conectar con ese público al que
queremos querer estar hablando el que
está alejado de la disciplina y no se
trata de destruirlo se trata de abrir
una vía de comunicación un diálogo
gestar el debate las sociedades
científicos anónimos llevamos tres años
realizando eventos mensuales en cantinas
y aunque les podría sonar un poco contra
intuitivo que estará un debate en 350
personas en una cantina sobre
superbacterias o sobre agujeros negros o
anorexia créanme que funciona y funciona
muy bien porque le quita esa solemnidad
que a veces acompaña a estas iniciativas
entonces estamos empezar a hacer más
iniciativas de comunicación de la
ciencia que pongan énfasis en las
emociones que valoren la imaginación que
rescaten la reflexión personal
necesitamos bajar a la ciencia de ese
pedestal de que a veces se le considera
humanizar a la disciplina
dejar de retratarla como una máquina de
certidumbres y de hacerlo como lo que es
como un oficio falible con posibilidades
de equivocarse y retractarse cambiarse y
mejorar
necesitamos pues una divulgación que
haga eco de esta visión tan integral que
se caracteriza bajo un bolt
entonces pues para los científicos y los
comunicadores es su deber evitar que
seamos como esos peces de la fábula de
wallace a estas alturas nadie debería
ignorar que es el agua ni para el caso
creer que la tierra es plana y para la
sociedad
la serpiente ya nos mordió y no es una
mordida seca la cuenta regresiva está en
marcha que vamos a hacer al respecto
[Aplausos]